in 45 al litro il segno in questa scuola
non mi ero mai e dico mai capitata una
classe indisciplinata come la costa ve
lo devo proprio dire siete la classe
peggiore dell'intero istituto
complimenti senti vari sembra questo il
modo dei sederti che sei in spiaggia
ansa sorin non si va in bagno ma prima
ora ragazzi le vogliamo aprire queste
finestre
dobbiamo cambiare l'aria non si respira
qui dentro
guardate che ai miei tempi e si dava
anche lo zero come volto e 40 annunci ha
bisogno di appoggiarsi alla parete
guarda che quella sta in piedi da sola
non cade non si va in bagno prima della
riparazione svolta a chiudere le
finestre perché si gela qui dentro è
siete ancora peggio i ragazzi di prima
che i bambini dell'asilo si comportano
meglio di voi che voglio ricordate il
telefono lo usa solo per questioni
scolastiche
scusate cesare senti cambia ancora
un'oretta che finisco qua la lezione e
poi arrivò a casa va bene e appena
finita la ricreazione e tu non sei
andato in bagno sono cavoli tuoi
ti senti questo qua cosa sono mele pere
carote vogliamo metterla l'unità di
misura ogni tanto
pensate che mi piaccia da di tutti
questi compiti a casa
sì mi piace a loro la vostra una
generazione che non ha più valori
ragazzi siete sempre attacca guest i
telefonini ne dia la prima ora verifica
su tutto il programma ma weekend a tutti
se vuoi togliere quel cappellino non
siamo mica un concerto rock ragazzi sono
sincera i ragazzi delle altre classi
sono molto più avanti di voi col
programma all'ultima ora c'è la tieni e
la fai a casa tua
cioè qualche volontario no allora chiamo
io chiudo avviso il prossimo richiedi
sono corretti compiti viene sospeso
immediatamente se ci fosse un esame per
diventare asini lo passa e verso tutti
ragazzi se non avete capito ditemelo è
che ve lo rispiego proprio non ho capito
perché non stai attento devi stare più
attento non è che posso sempre di
spiegare stesse cose mute arrangi è
andare in bagno chiari come l'inglese is
now you can't qualcuno voglia di andare
a fare due fotocopie
tu che non è alzato la mano dai ragazzi
so che ultima ora e siete stanchi ma
sono stanca anche io allora io che ho 55
anni due figlie separata con l'ernia al
disco 200 studenti 60 classi e non vado
in bagno dalle 7 del mattino e poi siete
già in continente così giovani
allora ragazzi è molto importante tutto
quello che so per scrivere ricopiate ero
perché poi ve lo trovate nel compito va
bene e poi non dite che non vogliono
avvisato
[Musica]
bene spero che abbiamo copiato tutti
guardate che lo stato mi paga lo stesso
io vi faccio non vi faccia lezioni
uguale io guadagno comunque siete voi
che non impara a per niente ma è
possibile che non riesco neanche a
sentito ragazzo che sta un metro di
distanza da me per colpa di tutto il
casino che fate laggiù in fondo la
smettete di fare salotto non siamo mica
mercato qui a loro ragazzi mi sembra di
aver capito che non vi è chiaro è allora
vi faccio un altro schema così magari
capite
va bene menzione questo magari era un po
complicato adesso ve ne faccio uno più
semplice allora più chiaro vero allora
io amo il mio lavoro ma voi vi fate
proprio basta che lo voglia mi son
dimenticato di dirvi una cosa e poi non
di pete non vi avevo avvisato
se questo video vivevano molto nella
laica girerò un altro video si
professori e mi raccomando se non
l'avete ancora fatto iscrivere se già
questo canale
non le dico più e soprattutto seguitemi
sugli altri social graham che ha detto
le mie foto in bikini e anche su tutte
top che faceva aletti lo sapete già
anche su facebook va bene basta mi sono
stufata me ne vado ciao
[Musica]